well i just think you need evidence like
we live in this society where it's like
believe people with no with no evidence
yeah and people can like like a girl can
accuse a guy of something with
like nothing and ruin a career or like
get public thousands of people online
like watching him
like tarnishing his reputation with no
evidence that it happened yeah i think
even when evidence exists to the
contrary
sometimes the justice system fails men
especially in the last five years
whereby
judges or whoever aren't even looking at
the evidence that proves that the guy is
innocent but still because you're a guy
and there's a big movement it's easier
to sort of go against you and fall on
the sword rather than
stand up and then it's like oh women are
more vulnerable now and then they're
more victims and it's like
there needs to be fairness whoever's a
perpetrator needs to be done for right
right well because it was a belief
believe all women like
i can't believe i used to be everywhere
and i remember like being
back then thinking this is madness
because i know some crazy [ __ ] yeah i
know some crazy [ __ ] you should not
believe i think that's so dangerous
though
it's so dangerous but the movement was
so big that if you spoke against it
everyone's on you everyone would come
after you you get cancelled right
but now this whole johnny depp thing
it's almost like a breath of fresh air
kind of thing
because it sort of brings back some sort
of balance to say well actually
maybe some women do lie and it's not
just whatever a woman says it's true i'm
not saying that amber heard is a liar
and that johnny depp isn't whatever he
is but it at least brings another
conversation
some sort of balance yeah there's at
least that conversation to be like what
if whereas before it wasn't what if it
was we don't care you're a guy she said
you did this you didn't get [ __ ] up
and they um
they
they would give like i think that the
news outlets should be held accountable
that we're pushing amber heard [ __ ]
to be honest you're you're giving a girl
a platform with no evidence that's so
irresponsible yeah but news i think
don't think they actually have an
obligation they don't necessarily
yeah and what's being reported a lot of
the time the whole vibe of things comes
from social media and social media are
pushing this feminist movement yeah when
which is like a believable woman thing
which they're still pushing no but i'm
saying like like they gave her an op-ed
so it's one thing to say these are the
facts and this is what she said and
there's another thing to like let her
write an article on your paper
yeah but all they care about is are
people going to read that paper yeah i
know because you've got no obligation to
find anything what's an op-ed
an app i don't it's it's like when you
get
i don't know is that they can edit they
can be an editor of uh
an article i guess but yeah
a newspaper paid
page opposite the editorial page devoted
to personal comment feature articles
yeah so if it's personal comments i just
know she like wrote it
and she didn't say him by name but like
it almost seems like there should be
laws in place that that punish women and
men honestly for for going on public
platforms and talking saying [ __ ] that's
not true and it just seems for like a
little point
in
in our history like there really was no
punishment during that movement
do you guys agree disagree no i agree i
don't even know what that movement was
me too
oh me too yeah
yeah the me too movement and the
believer women yeah yeah no that's that
was a bit mad because you could see that
some of them are liars
some of them are clout chasers
but then i i saw i
when that was the whole me too movement
was going on i used to see the sort of
graph here that would say
like two percent of women would lie
about being graped and then it would be
like 98 are telling the truth so what
does this really mean yeah you know what
i mean so
it made me think what do i believe who
does that survey though like how does
they always say like one in five women
have been sexually assaulted that's not
true how is that not true
no because they include things like like
a guy grabbing your ass at a boat
i was sexually assaulted in in when i
was in year eight what would you say
sexual assault when i was in year eight
yeah before i went to school um i went
to mcdonald's to get mcflurry before i
went to school and as i was queuing up
here this man he came behind me and i'm
bearing the man i mean yeah hey i'm in
my school uniform and he was like
groping my bum and at first i thought it
was in my head so i kind of like moved
away from him but lo and behold there he
was again behind me groping my bum and
then i knew no it's not in my head i am
being sexually assaulted right now did
you know it at the time yeah i went to
school when i told teachers but i'm
saying like okay that's gross he should
not have done that like that's
disgusting he's touching an underage
girl like that that's messed up so
that's gross but like my point was that
there's a difference like they made it
seem like at the time one in four women
was getting graped when like like i've
had how do we i've had
i've i've had my butt grabbed at a bar i
wasn't traumatized i was like get the
[ __ ] yeah but that's not that but that's
still the same
question
can i just ask a question yeah because i
just feel like yeah that there are
different definitions of what grape
could be 100 because you see sometimes
yeah you could find yourself with a guy
and he could be pressuring you so much
you don't want to do it but you could be
scared you could be uncomfortable and
you might just end up giving it
yeah so is that great there's like
there's there's like because he
pressured you coercion yes that is yeah
i don't think yeah so yeah no it is
whether you think it or not that is
classified as great wait what would you
define as coercion let me just
understand like manipulation i would say
manipulation if if i as a guy i'm fully
aware the woman is not interested in
having sex with me whether it's today or
whether we had sex yesterday and today
she's not interested if i'm fully aware
and i
i pressure her so let me let me just so
okay me and you we go on a date right
after the day we go back to my place
and i i say i don't want to hook up with
you and then you try to convince me
is that coercion i would say it is yeah
yes okay i think sometimes i don't i
just yeah
if he's in your place yeah yeah you
could feel intimidated so you could end
up no no but why did you go there yeah
why did i bring him because so say for
example we went on a date now and then
we agree you agreed to come back to mind
i asked you do you want to come back to
mind we have drinks and whatnot we you
come back to mine and then we're in the
same bed mm-hmm and then i try to emoji
you know mm-hmm and then you're like no
no i'm not what now i tried i tried to
like draw me i tried to get things
cracking i tried to motion you
i tried to motion i tried to get things
cracking yeah and then obviously you're
like no no no
and then i'm trying to like yo i'm
trying to sweet you up
and you're still like no i'm like all
right cool that's it
don't say that's it yeah they will keep
on going and going and going
turns into a yeah
but in some some girls will be like oh
you're not up front because you didn't
really push it
because there's moments where that does
happen no but i'm saying so i've been in
situations where guys pressured me and i
told him to get the f out yeah like it's
not there's a difference
and
like trying to get it cracking do you
know what i mean yeah no there is but
that's what i'm saying if ultimately you
know she's not on it yeah no matter what
yeah and she ends up doing it because of
that but how was the guy supposed to
know but how is the guy supposed to know
when some girls change their mind i
agree some girls want to be like they do
play hard to get here
can i make another plan
but that's wrong though so like
i obviously yes like let your no be a no
and i think just in life like a no is a
no so if someone says no okay i will
take the no brother i like you saying no
or not i have to accept that because
that was your answer
i have i have two more examples here
so the first one i think i forgot the
second one but the first one here is
what about being intoxicated yeah you
could be so intoxicated that you
physically cannot give consent but you
still end up having sex yeah that's my
first example my second example is yeah
is say for instance here you two are
together yeah and i don't know it's
early on in the relationship and you
haven't discussed yeah how you might
feel if he wakes you up with a bit of
dick but then one morning you wake up
and you've got a dick inside you is that
great that is that is yeah it is oh yeah
because you haven't discussed that
you're cool with that yet if you just
put it in exactly but i think
but i don't think it's i don't think
it's grape if you do something because
you you feel bad or you feel like you
have to
is it i'm not asking that like 100
percent hit me up the example was that
uh you're in a relationship something
you haven't really discussed yeah does
it become great irrespective or is it
only if she doesn't like it oh she says
no i didn't i didn't consent to that if
i'm asleep how can i
blurred the light because equally if it
was the reverse and and
yeah i know
it was a reverse and the guy's sleeping
and she wants to give him head to wake
him up
it's like it's that there's a there's a
blurred line
and that's where the loop is
yeah no but i think i think it's it's
wrong either way like i don't care no
but i feel like because we're in this
discussion now you you're saying no it's
wrong no but in reality just in general
like just just society people wouldn't
think that's wrong yes it's like
a girl now touches my piece and what's
the but you need to discuss it first no
but you should
so you're saying that just because i go
to someone's house like if i go or they
come to mind that means we're
automatically having sex no i i
shouldn't be obligated to have sex
doesn't it doesn't mean you're obligated
but what i'm saying is like
it's like
like you can kick him out you can tell
him to leave and if he's the type of guy
you would be scared with he shouldn't be
at your apartment but people can change
people can't yeah people can be people
but i don't think i think that's the
exception rather than the rules i don't
think most men are like that
but some some people are predators as
well
yeah i know but again we're picking the
extreme guy like most guys i've i've had
guys at my like apartment and i didn't
sleep with them and most guys if you
tell them no they'll listen i think your
point is even if they are a predator
like so what you are still able to sort
of say yes or no yeah
yeah
and i don't think it's like oh i think
he might great me so sleep with him like
that doesn't noise i think that men
should definitely understand to like um
not manipulate women in a certain way
but i
i think that women have to understand
that some men can't control themselves
in it if you if if a woman agrees to
come back to a man's crib yeah
understand that not all men can control
themselves if they have a woman there
because they might not have a woman
therefore yeah she's great
so yeah should i tell you something here
um
there was this guy
and um i thought we were friends
and um
like but i don't know he was just he's
just a bit weird
and then it's like um
one time i went to his house i heard
bear stories like this and i said to him
like you know like we're cool whatever
whatever whatever like he was all right
and then
um when i was leaving i was like let me
eat a [ __ ]
i don't know i was like what but it's
like he kept on kept on kept on asking
me and i was like no no i need to leave
now
so i've left now and then like he he's
messaging me oh like your queen you're
this you're i want to marry you
xyz and i'm just like look i don't want
to be nasty in it like i've already told
him that like i don't like you like that
isn't it like i think we should just be
friends
and he even said that rola i i can't be
your friend didn't it because i can't i
can't control myself yeah
some people say and and it doesn't
surprise me because you're a [ __ ]
weirdo
yeah but it sounds like yeah he did
control himself no he didn't i left no
but that's like right it wasn't like he
grabbed you or anything technically he
did control him yeah technically he did
it he didn't he didn't he didn't fam
yeah because he knew before i even went
there he knew we are friends yeah i've
gone there to do content with him do you
understand so if i've come here on the
of under the guise that we're doing
content you shouldn't then be saying you
shouldn't be then making me feel
uncomfortable putting me on the spot
asking to do these sexual things to me
and then once i've said no you're still
persistent to ask me that's not
controlling yourself see that's more
context because at first it was like you
just went over there okay there's the
context if you're going there for a
specific reason and it's nothing to do
with sexual stuff
then that's that's [ __ ] up like yeah
no but even so sometimes even when guys
can't differentiate what not what
what they've got to get yeah they can't
differentiate what's playing hard to get
and what's
what's actually you know sometimes we
have to okay i don't want to say one
but i'm saying sometimes you have to
understand women yeah let's say i'm
using social medias in liverpool a lot
because that's what young people look at
most of the time yeah and the whole
narrative is ah
like i love playing hard to get it
young guys you know what i mean yeah but
we said if a girl wants sex so she's not
going to be a manipulative sometimes to
go back getting it like yeah
i mean she will be she will be but then
playing hard to get and actually like
say no it's a very thin line it's a
feeling the difference between a woman
playing hard to get and not being
interested anyone now the difference is
when you just know like no you're in the
moment let's see if it's exactly what no
because women will go on dates even if
they're not interested in the guy yeah
so you can't know
i've also seen girls like i've also seen
girls
be all up like over a guy and like even
like we're in like you know a party type
environment i'm thinking she's like
bringing him to bringing him back you
know and then she'll like like turn
around be like oh my god he's so creepy
i'm like what you're all over him yes
and i'm like i see stuff like that i'm
like she wants his non-sexual attention
yeah i mean i'm not interested in you
and the guy's like you know she wants me
still like she's she just doesn't know
here no
listen the lines are so blurred and pete
i was i was mid
pump
okay and the girl was like stop
like stop repeatedly and i was like oh
[ __ ] and i stopped and she was like
you're not actually supposed to stop why
are you stopping
you know
no but you can't say hello because what
happens the next girl who says
you can stop yeah a lot of men out there
i'll even say more than half a man out
there you can't control themselves i
can't stop you
like that's that's [ __ ] because i've
had lots of times i'm stopping
why are you stopping and it's not even
why you stopping it's like oh what a
[ __ ] why are you stopping yeah like
[ __ ] all right you got me and it's like
and i'm like yo
it's a strong thing if i can stop i'm
sorry
i just think it's like i'm just big into
like accountability yeah yeah so like i
think a lot of times like i've been in
situations where i'm like well i
shouldn't have put myself in that
situation some people would like like
yeah yeah
they can't like even even in your
situation like i've been in a place
where i thought the guy like might be
trying to like i was going somewhere for
content i just always bring a third
person
if it's a dude and like i've never
really met him like i'm bringing a third
person no i'd met him before
and he was friends with my cousin oh
okay so you kind of knew him through
friends
so i didn't really feel like it needed
to be like that
but then when he actually said like
you're not like i can't be friends with
girls i can't control myself
definitely understood why i think
i think at any blurred lines you should
remove yourself so whether it's a
a female or a male whatever yeah like if
you are confused that's your answer that
means no like you should never you
should be certain